all right so today I got a hold of and
got to poke around the new iPhone 15 and
the iPhone 15 Pros I do remember flying
here and I'm thinking what could Apple
possibly do like what could they
possibly introduce with a new iPhone the
23rd iPhone that's actually interesting
now there is more stuff than just the
iPhone that was mentioned at this Wonder
lust event that Apple hosted including
some stuff that straight up wasn't
mentioned on stage at all so we'll get
to that but this is just the new iPhone
stuff so stay tuned to get subscribed to
see the rest but let's just talk about
the new iPhone 15 and 15 Pro so here's a
lens to look at all this stuff through
coming into this basically everything
Apple just added to their newest
Flagship phones falls into two buckets
it's either something we've already seen
in some other phone for years or it's
some ecosystem feature that only works
with other iPhones which is not
necessarily a bad thing but it's just
just a lens to look through this stuff
at just to keep an eye on it so this is
the iPhone 15 there's the same two sizes
again iPhone 15 and iPhone 15 plus and
yeah you know there's some small changes
like the slight soft Corner radi on the
aluminum rails and the one piece glass
back fading between a lighter and darker
version of the same color like this new
pink one it's pretty seamless also satin
soft touch backs across the whole lineup
instead of glossy I definitely like that
but the big headlining feature really is
it's USB now lightning is officially
dead these new iPhones are all USBC
across the board now on one hand this is
a huge deal like there's only ever been
one Port change in the iPhone ever back
in 2012 we went from that 30 pin
connector thing to this new lightning
thing which we've had ever since and now
the second one ever is USB type-c but on
the other hand it's I don't know it's
just USB like it's the same port all
these other laptops and tablets all over
the planet I've had for the past couple
years I imagine it might be another year
or two before the whole lineup like the
Baseline cheap iPad and the iPhone SC
and everything else gets USBC but yeah I
don't know we knew it was coming but
it's still kind of surreal to look at an
iPhone and see a USB port on it so what
does this enable it's a real question
right uh first of all it's the one cable
that you can ideally use to charge all
your stuff so your Mac your iPad your
iPhone your friends Android phone the
new airpods which just got a new USBC
case all that stuff one cable oh and now
you can charge accessories like the new
airpods with the wire so there's no
Wireless reverse charging right now but
that ctoc cable that comes in the Box so
you can like plug it in the iPhone plug
it into the airpods and charge the
airpods up from the iPhone battery so
that's pretty cool but they did hold
back on one very key thing and they
saved it for the iPhone 15 Pro so I'll
get to that in a bit but that's USBC
aside from that really it's a slightly
updated phone it's a little bit of a new
display you know you get the dynamic
Island here of course on these Baseline
iPhones and there's also now a higher
Peak brightness 2,000 nits now which is
twice as bright as the iPhone 14s and
there's a new camera the primary camera
is now a 48 megapixel chip presumably
the same one that was in the iPhone 14
pro last year and all the benefits that
come with that and then the rest of the
phone really follows that same formula
they do this thing where the new
Baseline phone is basically last year's
Pro phone repackage so it inherits the
same a16 Bionic chip from last year's
Pro phone the coolest feature of this
phone though and you know it's also in
the Pro phone but I still think it's
pretty solid is the camera has this new
Next Generation portrait mode but
basically automatically detects when
there's a subject in a photo and
captures all of the depth information
needed to be able to turn it into a
portrait mode photo later so you don't
have to remember to switch it to
portrait mode necessarily every time and
if you ever forget but want to add that
blur later you can do it with high
quality results so that's cool aside
from that the rest of the phone I mean
it's the same thing right same sizes
guys same ceramic Shield same dust and
water resistance and same starting
prices $7.99 for the 15 and $8.99 for
the 15 plus so then there is the pro
phones the iPhone 15 Pro and 15 Pro Max
there is some more new here a lot of it
I'm actually want to going to want to
test just to see if it's actually what
they say but make sure you get
subscribed to see those full reviews
when they come out later this month and
we can figure out if the phones are
worth it but basically it's not bleeding
edge stuff that we've never seen before
it's just welcome stuff and those are
mostly in build quality the chip inside
and the cameras so let's just start with
the chip inside first of all it's a
brand new chip that's called the A7 Pro
it's the first time they've used the
word Pro in an iPhone chip and it's
their first 3 nanometer chip so it
promises some performance and efficiency
improvements as a result I think they
said it's like 10% faster high
performance cores and the neural engines
up to twice as fast bunch of other stuff
not sure how much of this you'll
actually notice in everyday use but hey
future proofing and Headroom is never a
bad thing so this is clearly a powerful
chip they showed a demo of a game with
like faster raid tracing which isn't new
but you know it helped make their point
but the interesting thing to note here
with this chip is they mentioned the
chip has a new usb3 controller on it
which means the 15 and 15 plus don't
have that so basically that means the
pro iPhone's USBC Port actually gets
upgraded usb3 speeds the faster data
transfer speeds up to 10 gbits per
second but the base iPhones without that
controller they get USBC but they're
going to be stuck at USB 2.0 speeds
basically the same we've always had with
lightning like 480 megabits per second
now this probably won't make a real
difference to most people like I don't
know when the last time you plugged your
phone in was but it's kind of a bummer
that not all of the benefits of USBC
come to all of the phones uh but for the
pro phones that are going to be shooting
more prores video or Pro Raw photos I
mean it takes forever if you've shot
this stuff like I have you know it takes
forever to get those off of the phone
cuz they're big files
so I kind of wish they'd gone all the
way I wish they' done Thunderbolt speeds
20 30 40 megabits gigabits per second uh
but yeah it's it's just going to be USB
3 on the pro iPhones and USB 2 on the
bass iPhones you know what is
disappointing though no fast charging
like this I talked about this on the
podcast on waveform I'll try to link the
episode below but like switching the
USBC you'd think oh this is a huge
opportunity for Apple to like explain
why they're doing it and we know why
they're doing it but oh why are you
giving us this new port and all this
this big new USBC deal and it's it's
just the same 20 or so watt charging
we've had for the iPhone for forever no
new fast charging kind of figured they
would try to do that better but yeah
this will still take an hour and a half
2 hours to charge but anyway the new
design is what most people are fawning
over at the moment with the pros so they
have switched the rails from that shiny
fingerprint stainless steel to this new
grade five titanium alloy with a brushed
texture and it's nice it is first of all
it's noticeably lighter in the hand
which I love and it seems like it's also
enabled them to shrink the body of the
pro iPhones just a little bit so they
have the same screen sizes but the
screens now get even closer to the edges
and there's even thinner slightly
thinner bezels and I actually do notice
that now a lot of people are also
quoting stronger as one of the benefits
too but I really don't think this is
going to make as much of a difference as
people are thinking like the pro iPhones
have had this stainless steel rails for
a while now I've dropped this phone as
you know I don't have a case on the
ground I've dented the stainless steel
rails it's fine it doesn't break it's
not the stainless steel that breaks it's
a glass that breaks and as far as we can
tell it's the same ceramic shield glass
on the iPhone 15 Pro that hasn't changed
so if you drop it on the glass you're
still going to have not great results uh
but yeah technically sure titanium is
stronger either way the new colors are
black white and this new blue which is
really subtle
and then natural which I guess it kind
of Embraces the raw titanium feel
reminds me of Starlight if you're
curious kind of like this warm tone
weirdly I think I like it the most but
also something else Apple said on stage
and this this was pretty quick so you
might not have even picked it up but
they did mention that they have
redesigned a bit of the interior of the
chassis to make the back glass more
replaceable so it's a more repairable
iPhone design technically it's a small
thing it's just one little step but it's
a step in the right direction for a more
repairable iPhone but my favorite
feature and before we get to any of the
cameras I honestly think this is my
favorite feature is uh the new action
button a new customizable button on the
side of the iPhone just the pro iPhone
so it replaces the mute switch which is
pretty iconic but it's in the same spot
as the mute switch and it it's actually
customizable so it's a pretty small
button basically about the same size as
the switch and by default it actually
behaves just like the mute switch did so
you you actually hold it down to switch
between muted or ringer on great but if
you dive into the settings there's
actually a section for this action
button and it's actually really in-depth
and super solid it basically lets you go
through and pick the function of the
button and there's way more here than I
expected so you can keep the mute switch
on or you can have it switch you in and
out of a certain Focus mode like do not
disturb or you could pick whichever
other one you want you could also have
it auto launch the camera and pick
whichever camera mode it opens you could
also do flashlight turning on or opening
up voice memos or it can toggle the
magnifier or the last option actually is
you can have it trigger a series
shortcut which as you know can
technically do almost anything including
basically launching any app on your
phone I think there may be a bit of a
delay from the button press to the app
opening if I'm thinking about this
correctly like it's done in the past but
I'll have to test that for the full
review but theoretically you can map
this button to open whatever your
calendar app your to-do list app
whatever app you want which is totally
not what I expected to be on the list of
things you could do with a new button on
the side of the iPhone but now you can
but then last but not least the new
cameras across the board here there's a
new larger 48 megapixel main sensor for
the pros and improved Ultra wide and
then the pro Max just the pro Max gets a
new intricate folding 5x telephoto
camera I'm guessing if I asked Apple
they would say that there was only
enough room in the bigger Pro Max to fit
this folding lens I'll ask we'll see
what they say but until then the regular
15 Pro is going to still have the 3x
telephoto the regular 3x from last year
and then we found this seemingly random
feature it's in the settings they also
talked about it in the keynote but where
you can change your default focal length
to be either 1X or
1.2x or
1.5x for some reason so it's buried in
the middle of the camera settings but
you can tell it to default to one of
these specific three focal links so if
you switch back to the camera app that
1X button is now always going to take
you to the new focal length that you've
chosen and you can still get to 1x or
whatever other focal length you want but
I just found that interesting so maybe
if you somehow if you're someone that
takes 1.2x photos so often that you want
a button to get there as fast as
possible because it's the perfect focal
length for you then sure maybe if you're
a photographer you don't want to do the
work of digital cropping just hit that
focal length every time sure but there's
been a lot of comments that at the end
of the day it feels like USB is
literally the big biggest headlining new
feature of this year's new iPhone which
is crazy I I can't quite get rid of my
lightning cable yet there's still some
accessories there's like mag safe Duo
there's airpods Max there's like the
magic Trackpad there's a couple things
that still are lightning now maybe
they'll switch that in the next couple
months but now I'm genuinely curious if
there's going to be a bunch of new USBC
phone accessories because of the iPhone
getting USBC uh similar to our sponsor
of this video ankor so they've made a
whole new lineup products for the iPhone
15 headlined by the anchor Nano which is
like this little small But Mighty USBC
power bank that can crank out 30 Watts
with the built-in USBC cable and you can
also charge it up 30 WTS and if you have
that little button up at the top here
it'll actually show a literal percentage
of how much battery you have left or if
you're plugged in it'll show you a time
which counts down so you really know
exactly how much of the 10,000 milliamp
hours you have left plus there's some
other stuff in the lineup there's a wall
charger braided USBC cables Galore so
feel free to learn more about Anchor's
new line up at the link below and shout
out to Anker for sponsoring this video
so iPhone 15 Pro will start at the same
price as last year which is $9.99 but
they've bumped up iPhone 15 Pro Max
sneakily interestingly it will start at
$1.99 but it's also the only one with a
5x camera and it's the only one that
starts at 256 gigs and last year the
price of the 256 gig Pro was the same so
you're kind of matching it's just like
getting rid of the $1,100 phone for some
reason either way let me know if you're
interested in these new iPhones at all
you're either in Camp don't care at all
or you're in Camp like totally getting
one of these or maybe you're watching to
see if the reviews prove that the new
features are worth it let me know what
you're thinking comment section's always
open thanks for watching and I'll catch
you in the next one get subscribe see
you later
[Music]
peace